tonight we're tracking multiple major
stories including new developments from
the russia collusion hoax a top biden
advisor has now been implicated in
connection to the lies conspiracy
theories found in hillary clinton's
dirty russian paid for dossier plus
america's most dishonest congressman
adam schiff yep for the first time he is
facing tough questions and by the way
surrounding his deep involvement in
perpetrating the great lie hoax uh
conspiracy theory of the dossier and by
the way not from jake capper at fake
news cnn not chucky todd at msdnc
morgan ortegas on the view and we've got
the tape but first tonight we begin it
appears that joe biden has finally
realized americans are not happy with
the u.s economy but according to joe the
only fiscally responsible way to make
things better is to pass the build back
better
new green deal socialism plan and spend
a couple trillion more dollars that we
don't have and rob our kids and
grandkids blind and put it on social
welfare projects that are pretty much
destined to fail
every single economist in the country
not named janet yellen is warning this
spending would greatly accelerate
inflation which is now impacting all of
us at a time when inflation is already
at a 30-year high well we got bad news
today wholesale prices they are up a
whopping 8.6 percent we already know gas
prices are up on average a dollar fifty
a gallon costs a lot more to fill your
tank the cost to heat and cool your home
well it could be up by a hundred percent
by the end of the winter heating your
home and you might not even be able to
find a turkey in time for thanksgiving
why because of dire real shortages that
we're experiencing but joe biden he
knows best he's the smartest person in
the room and now he believes that
spending two trillion dollars is going
to magically fix inflation and fix our
supply chain crisis after all his
policies have worked so great to this
point right why not just um take his
word for it right
all this is paid for by raising taxes on
big corporations and very wealthy i'm
not trying to punish anybody but i'm
insisting that they pay their fair share
it's fiscally responsible and it's paid
for now i know that a lot of folks don't
feel the progress we're making in the
economy
i get it
i know the cost of gas groceries and
rent seems to be harder and harder to
handle
that's what's more that's one of the
most more reasons why we have to pass my
bill back better building
so it's one of the other biden is either
really really dumb not particularly
smart or he's lying probably both
remember on the campaign trail joe vowed
to punish the fossil fuel industry
reduce america's supply on oil and gas
even if it caused economic pain and
suffering for americans all around the
country you wanted to put ceos in jail
take a look
would you be willing to sacrifice some
of that growth
even knowing potentially that it could
displace thousands maybe hundreds of
thousands of blue-collar workers in the
interest of transitioning to that
greener economy the answer is yes
the answer is yes if we don't stop using
fuels
we're all dead doing away with any
subsidies for fossil fuels number one
number two holding them liable
for what they have done particularly in
those cases where your underserved
neighborhoods and you you know the deal
okay and by the way when they don't when
they're deliberate put them in jail
that's what i'm from i'm not joking
not joking but let's put these guys in
jail he did keep one promise he killed
the keystone xl pipeline he did ban oil
exploration on federal lands and now his
administration is weighing an option to
kill another pipeline this one from
canada to michigan and that's not all
according to the great climate czar the
guy with the big carbon footprint
himself john kerry the u.s will no
longer have coal plants by 2030 thanks
to build back better new green deal
socialism by the way senator joe manchin
i think you might want to pay attention
because that will impact west virginia
and the hard-working people in your
state even with heating prices gas
prices soaring biden has no intention
clearly of slowing down his green new
deal agenda it's so bad that in a letter
11 senate democrats apparently they're
the only 11 that paid attention to what
happened last tuesday they are now
slamming joe biden and the undue burden
of rising gas prices that his policies
have caused or something to laugh at
like his energy secretary jennifer
granholm did but let's get clear here
this could all easily be resolved we can
fix all of this
except we have one problem joe biden's
president
joe biden apparently clearly would
rather once again beg opec
again and again and again and get
rejected
again and again and again in humiliating
fashion and still keep going back as
jennifer granholm blaming the cartels
blaming opec no jennifer i blame you and
i blame joe and if you really want to
fix the problem go back to the energy
independence that you inherited from
donald trump who made us energy
independent for the first time in 75
years and that means we can create a lot
of jobs right here in america high
paying career jobs in the energy sector
and we won't have to care one wit about
what happens in the middle east or the
straits of hormuz and we'll be energy
independent if you have cheaper a better
form cleaner form of energy i'm an all
the above guy bring it forward in the
meantime oil gas and coal are the
lifeblood of the world's economy and
begging opec is not the answer you know
we can drill for more gas right here in
the u.s we don't need to import any
energy donald trump gave you energy
independence and we were a net exporter
of energy we were supplying our western
european allies biden he'd rather give
the waiver to vladimir putin's pipeline
than keep building out our own keystone
xl pipeline that's american jobs now
he's floating the possibility of
draining our national reserves okay
that's a short-term solution that's also
risky and tonight our country is
literally being led by some of the
dumbest people they're more married to
their ideology don't seem to care at all
about who is impacted negatively the
most poor people the middle class build
back better new green deal socialism is
probably the most idiotic scariest piece
of legislation i've seen in my 33 years
in media joe's actions surrounding
afghanistan are morally corrupt his
southern border policy ludicrous
according to a poll from trafalgar
that's her friend robert kahale and the
convention of states 67 percent of
americans oppose biden's plan to give a
whopping 450
to illegal immigrants that didn't
respect our laws our border and our
sovereignty 55 percent want the southern
border closed especially in the middle
of the crisis that's ongoing down there
the borders are kamala harris who has a
historically low approval rating for any
vice president at only 28 percent what
is she doing on the border she's not
going down there and visiting the guys
on the front lines nope she's in paris
in france talking about europe's migrant
crisis how does that help us and
according to the vice president
spokeswoman she's not at all worried
about the 28 record low poll number
she's pulling take a look
i'm not focused on the polls i'll let
the pundits pontificate on that the
polls are a snapshot in time and at this
time i am looking forward to touching
down in paris france but before that
taking a nap
now nap time seems to be a priority
across the biden administration the old
only silver lining in 2022 2024 you the
american people you can vote all of
these people out you can say bye bye and
we can return to let's see maybe we'll
even go back and rescue the americans
joe abandoned in afghanistan we
certainly can fix the border bring back
the stay in mexico policy finish
building the wall
end this idiot policy idiocy of of
process and release of joe biden and
then of course we can go back to being
energy independent that will help our
economy as well that will reduce the
high cost of everything that we're now
paying for hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else